I have to navigate carefully when I talk
about you why because it goes into like
so uh wait he used to open for you
really yeah well then okay so you're
here at Chuck Chucks and he's way up
there how did that happen so I want to
avoid all that you know that happens
because this business isn't fair oh stop
it
random it's random come on save that
listen first of all you know I'm not
nice
that's not true I you've got the image
but I know Underneath It All you're a
caring sensitive guy it comes out I know
if you don't want people to know that
[__] YouTube you want everybody to know
Bill Burr [__] you guys you [__] [__]
but everybody knows you're really nice
everybody who knows you knows that dude
I got mad at a hanger yesterday
what did the hanger do it broke I just
took a shirt off it and it [__]
exploded and it just it just set me off
with this like like how much [__]
money do you have to make right and you
know they sit there going like okay they
can take the shirt off like 3.7 times
and then it's going to explode